you know I promised your mom that you
would only use this stuff when one of us
was around it's really dangerous Tech I
know it's dangerous what if the cops
took it from you what if you lost it I
didn't lose the suit you have a suit
wait you have a suit I know how to take
care of myself okay trust me I'm pretty
good at it by now
ouch
look I didn't mean it like that
that's okay it's all right I get it
I just think you should get to have a
normal life
dad a guy dressed like a bee tried to
kill me in my room when I was six
how about some music
in that moment all I could think was how
did the Hulk turn me into a baby
will I be a baby forever
am I the Hulk's baby dad are you
listening to your own book but I was
ready for it no that's uh Stephen this
is the radio's over there it's so weird
something's wrong with this
she won't turn up
turn it up all right a little after that
a raccoon raccoon space showed up I
don't think he knew my name I was just
happy to meet a raccoon who could talk